[Musique]
mais si ça va
la race rdas a empoisonné notre
haleine mondiale doit être éliminée
ils nous ont
tout pris bien moi
j'ai été formé à leurs manières leur
technologie
leurs armes
des choses qui ne sont pas ne devraient pas savoir
et puis  un jour,
ils ont quitté Hell's Gate est attaqué
évacuez maintenant
mais avant qu'ils ne le fassent, notre professeur nous a sauvés
et nous a endormis c'est votre seule
chance de survivre
et je reste là pendant 15 ans
jusqu'au jour où
je me suis réveillé
et j'étais libre
libre d'explorer  mon monde
libre de décider qui j'allais être
jamais ce que j'étais censé faire
[Musique]
tu es vraiment
maintenant Pandora est à nouveau attaquée
ne laisse pas la Navi nous gêner
débarrasse-toi d'eux et je  j'ai un choix à faire
je choisis de protéger ma maison
étranger
je ne suis plus
je ne suis pas moi
[Musique]
sivako